also too I think especially as women
we've been groomed to like want to go
shopping that's supposed to be sort of
the norm and it is fun and be like
pretty things but I think at some point
it becomes almost an addiction for like
we don't feel good so then we go to the
store so we can look for stuff so if
someone wanted to break that habit let's
say they don't want to acquire as many
things what are some things that people
could do where they're not consuming
things like what what are some
activities that you've replaced maybe
shopping with well before I jump into
the activities thing one thing that I've
really tried to make myself do over the
years is everything i buy i forced
myself to use so you know if i if i say
oh you know there's this I don't know a
new pieces of sporting goods including
cause accidents sort of my weaknesses is
gear of things I make myself do it like
if I have snowed if I get pair of
snowshoes I have make myself go
snowshoeing and then after doing that
sometimes if you really did you know you
actually buy things that you really
don't want to use and if you if you make
yourself use it then that you know then
you won't actually end up buying
something that you're not sure about in
the future because I think we know as
we're like reaching the to pick it up
you know it's like I bear bait I use
this you know but we just don't admitted
tourists I'll do that kind of convince
yourself you're going to use it sorry
that's just the right thing that I do
but I yeah I mean I think that you know
just thinking more about sort of doing
things rather than having things you
know and I think that um you know for me
maybe you know rather than going
shopping you know sometimes you know
going to meet a friend and hanging out
with friends or you know like finding a
new recipe and like you know doing
something creative or you know I'm a
writer so maybe it's like oh maybe I
should just sit down and work on this
project that I want to work on and I
feel like for me that's I sort of get
the same thrill you know it's sort of
buying something new of like
doing this thing that makes me feel
really satisfied and I'm really excited
about it and I feel like it kind of
fills the same need for me and you know
I think that in the people that we
talked to they find that when they have
to stop consuming the quality of their
life goes up because they have to fill
that space with all these other things
you know like like volunteering our
spending time with their friends or
their family or starting a business or
you know doing these things that maybe
they were kind of lazy about before
because they were able to you know buy
things so yeah I think there's also
maybe a psychological component 2 i'm
just thinking about all right hearing
that you know maybe maybe we buy things
because we it's one thing that we have
control over like how we spend our money
when maybe we feel so out of control our
lives that that you know say like you're
saying like with the addiction you know
and i think there's a lot of people who
go shop to make themselves feel better
in there depressed or whatever perhaps
that's to react it's like I can't
control the things that are happening in
my life but I can control this thing I
can like go in and buy that and nobody
can tell me you know yes or no and
that's what's hard is because you have
to tell yourself you should you know you
don't need that or whatever and yeah
sorry that's just a random thought yeah
i think you know as i'm thinking about
it more I to think you know for me the
thrill of sort of like making something
rather than buying something is kind of
a nice parallel you know kind of just
like being creative is is so much more
satisfying than sort of just going out
and getting something that's already you
know I've been been created by someone
else
you